so i'm really excited to work with
jensen apples new seasons mean new cast
members how did the actors and the boys
end up in their roles we've got 15 of
the wildest audition stories coming
right up
oh my gosh clearly we know where this is
going
number one he had the producer rooting
for him the production was looking at
some bigger names but eric kripke was
ready to fight for jensen after about
four rounds of tapes and notes kripke
felt confident in what they'd gotten
this was no easy feat though jensen had
to film a two-person scene but it was in
the middle of lockdown so his options
for readers to help him were limited so
he got creative i pre-recorded butcher
doing my butcher voice and then had
daniel off to the side pressing play and
pause so i was giving my lines to
soldier boy and then hearing my
pre-recorded butcher lines back to me
you do what you gotta do but guess what
there is this
fantastic opportunities number two
she hates auditioning and this was no
different any audition that comes her
way is typically a stressor but right
off the bat aaron moriarty started
really vibing with the material during
herself tape to play starlight the
actress shared it made me want the role
more i had to do a mini monologue and i
wasn't dreading it it wasn't anything
but pleasant and fun there was nothing
but radio silence for a month after her
first audition unfortunately but then a
surprise screen test was sprung on her
moriarty went through an excruciating
90-minute long screen test and the
actress left feeling like she'd blacked
out but before she left the marathon
kripke shared some pretty reassuring
words
just so you know no matter what happens
no matter what the studio decides
creatively we're rooting for you and we
know what happened after that
that is like i put that costume on and i
feel it like i feel like i step into her
and it's cool
number three this wasn't just any
audition tape tomer was in tel aviv with
a good friend to get his audition tape
done and he didn't hold back in bringing
the character frenchie to life he
screamed his lungs out in french take
after take but since they were filming
outdoors people nearby heard and got
worried next thing the after knew his
tape was interrupted by five undercover
cops raiding his yard one of the cops
who charged forward quickly recognized
the actor though and they stood down
tomer was much more careful after that
confessing i may have forgotten for a
moment where i live luckily i got the
job so we guessed the trouble was worth
it yeah i was aesthetic and hypnotic and
amazed by this guy number four
auditioning for the boys was a
surprisingly electrifying experience
quaid shared that aaron was the first
person to get cast and my first callback
was with her a chemistry read and our
first time ever meeting however his
second was the one that really shook him
the actor had a hard time articulating
exactly what it was like saying that was
the most surreal thing that's ever
happened in my life it was memorable to
say the least you know when i got cast i
i couldn't really believe it i i still
can't kind of can't believe it number
five this show was still a mystery when
the season two auditions began
ayakosh was intrigued but she wanted to
have a chat with the director first
since auditions were underway cash was
just given a longer audition time slot
to chat with kripke and while it all
went well enough cash wasn't confident
since everyone else she saw auditioning
looked very different from her but she
was proven wrong much to her delight
thing about stormfront is she's not
afraid of anybody which i think makes
her unique number six good friends tell
friends about auditions chase crawford
got lucky with his pals who mentioned he
should look into the project he pitched
it to his agent and they got him in but
his hopes weren't up when he saw about a
hundred other people auditioning for the
part luckily when he was in the room he
vibed with eric kripke explaining i had
him laughing i felt like we were on the
same page i felt good about it and soon
enough he got the call that the team
wanted him in for a screen test and the
rest is history but it was a great
moment to have with the crew and
everyone after a tough year so it was uh
it's awesome yeah number seven he feels
totally at home as homelander when
anthony star's management team suggested
he look into the script for the boys he
didn't jump on the opportunity right
away he didn't think he'd ever be cast
in that kind of a role but his team
wasn't about to let him pass up on the
opportunity then they were hassling so i
sat up in my dressing room and filmed
this audition almost out of spite for my
reps his fight didn't come through
though or maybe it did in the right way
since the casting team loved it and
wanted to see him again so star invested
some effort into it only to discover
just how special a project he had in
front of him he may have recorded his
screen test in a sketchy looking
basement but the passion was there that
was kind of surreal
number eight he didn't know what to
expect their people called his people
and the script for the boys landed in
carl urban's hands thinking about
playing billy butcher was an excellent
prospect urban even said i acknowledged
this would be a fun character to play
and i would be stupid to turn it down
from then i set up a meeting with eric
and seth rogen and decided there and
then i was going to be part of it no
audition needed in this case you know i
feel very blessed and privileged to be a
part of it number nine he didn't even
care for the comics before auditioning
las alonso had some chats with garth
ennis about mother's milk and getting to
hear what the character was all about
made alon so eager to be part of it and
the team was eager for him to be part of
it too alonso said the audition process
was good i improvised i made eric kripke
laugh and i got the role number 10
auditioning doesn't always happen at the
best of times jesse got the request to
audition which would normally be great
but he was in the weeds on set for a
film the result of the tape i sure
wasn't a fan i hated it so bad i sent an
email to my agent saying i can't send
this i'll get some sleep and send
something in the morning but this is not
something i want anyone to see he wound
up filming the tape again the next
morning but he had nothing to be worried
about since the team loved it um a train
somewhat had control over you know his
situation before everything hit the fan
number 11 second audition was the charm
for claudia her first audition for the
boys didn't go so well i originally came
in to audition for season 1 for the pr
woman i rightfully didn't get it but
that didn't stop her from being a fan of
the show she devoured the first season
in a day and a half and soon after she
got the chance to audition again she was
feeling confident sharing that this is
it i can tap into this and i just went
in and wore this suit and did my thing
number 12. the ideas in the comic world
really freaked him out but then he gave
them a chance the black moor actor
explained i got this this is pretty cool
the fact that he was also very
experienced in taekwondo was a major
help and for mitchell everything from
his first audition to his first day on
set felt natural number 13 sometimes the
best roles come as a fluke giancarlo was
surprised himself by how it all happened
in his own words all of this happened
completely by accident i was in a studio
in canada shooting jet and turned a
corner and there was eric kripke we're
just chatting what are you doing blah
blah blah and he takes that proverbial
director producer step back and crosses
his arms the actor knew an offer was
coming and it was music to kripky's ears
when he said i have joined the party now
number 14. he may be young but he's a
pro cameron crevetti has been building
up his credits in part thanks to the
help of his acting coach mom it was an
intense scene he had to audition with
but the series had already been released
when the audition came along so he got
to get a good understanding of what was
required they taped submitted and a
month later the good news came
number fifteen
the kimoko actress did her research read
some sides and was pretty quickly sold
on the roll
you could tell the show was incredible
so she gave it her all in the audition
clearly was a match made in heaven
auditions can make or break an actor and
while these didn't always go smoothly
clearly they all did something right
which audition sounds most overwhelming
to you